I did not ask about something that the
collider audience cares about alone and
that's the ending of arrow just curious
breaking news for you your show is
ending I am curious what you can say and
what you can say what to expect from the
end of era um well I watched the series
finale last night
[Music]
it's couldn't in the scene that the
series finale opens with is I can't wait
for people to see it so I can talk about
how it came to be
mm-hmm but it literally makes your head
go poof like that but for crisis on
Infinite Earths which starts Monday at
8:00 7:00 central on CW
man the first episode packs a punch and
if you're the second episode is just if
you love comic books you are gonna lose
your mind but it's it's really big it's
ambitious and even though it is a crisis
it's so much fun it really is parts the
first episode not so much gets there it
does series finales what you showed me
yeah the fight there's a fight scene in
the series finale that is to maybe the
best place okay so that I can't tell you
about the series finale is that we want
it to do a big it's like okay it's our
last kick as a can mm-hmm
let's do the let's do the action
sequence to end all action sequences for
arrow and the coolest thing is that I
want to say every stunt guy more or less
that has ever worked on the show even
guys that are now retired or
coordinating on Supergirl or flash or
legends everybody came out and everybody
sold out in terms of selling what was
happening it was it's a sequence that's
like I showed it to Robbie and
he's like that was incredible I'm like
that was the first third watching and it
just goes it's it's um it's a little
superfluous it's a little like you know
it's a little theatrical just in terms
of the amount of people that I murder
its is what the fans is what the fans
deserved